ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen
Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland
vertreiben auch Menschen mit einem
deutschen Pass darum ging es gestern
darum ging es bei einem geheimen Treffen
von Rechtsextremen in Potzdam im
November nicht gestern so ist es richtig
vergangenen Jahres dieses Treffen wurde
gestern öffentlich und zwar durch eine
Recherche von Korrektiv mit dabei
hochrangige Mitglieder der AFD
finanzstarke Unternehmen und andere
Figuren aus der rechtsextremen Szene wie
Martin selner der lange Sprecher der
identitären Bewegung in Österreich war
und als posterby und einer der
wichtigsten Ideengeber der neuen Rechten
im deutschsprachigen Raum gilt wir
wollen deshalb heute fragen welche
Gefahr für unsere Demokratie geht von
diesem Treffen aus welche Folgen hat es
für die AFD und wie wahrscheinlich ist
es dass ein wie jetzt von vielen
gefordertes AFD
parteierbotsverfahren tatsächlich kommt
darüber spreche ich mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Natascha
Strobel und mit dem Juristen Professor
Christian Waldoff der am
Verbotsverfahren der NPD mitgearbeitet
hat ihr könnt eure Fragen wie immer sehr
gerne direkt hier im Chat stellen oder
ihr schickt sie uns per Mail an die
angeblendete Adresse die lautet
zdfheute-live@zdf.de bevor wir jetzt
gleich direkt ins Gespräch einsteigen
wollen wollen wir euch einmal kurz
zusammenfassen wer an diesem Treffen
teilgenommen hat und um was es dabei im
Wesentlich ging und das haben Thomas
reicher und Ulrich Stol für euch
gemacht es ist ein kalter Novembertag an
dem im Landhaus adlom bei pozdam rund 30
Personen zu einem geheimen Treffen
zusammenkommen mit dabei hochrangige AFD
Mitglieder wie Ulrich Simond
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD in
SachsenAnhalt das recherchezentrum
Korrektiv konnte hier verdeckt Drehen an
dem Abend geht es um die Idee Millionen
Menschen abzuschieben auf solche mit
deutschem Pass die Einladung verspricht
einen Zitat Masterplan zur sogenannten
Remigration kein geringerer als Martin
selner werde das Vorstellen höchst
vertraulich das ist zner bei dem Treffen
leidfigur der rechtsextrem identitären
Bewegung sers Plan sieht vor auch
politisch missliebige Menschen nach
Afrika abzuschieben bei dem Treffen ist
auch der frühere AFD
Fraktionsgeschäftsführer Roland Hartwig
angeblich wusste er nicht dass sner
Auftritt Hartwig ist ein enger
Vertrauter von Bundessprecherin Alis
Weidel sie äußert sich nur schriftlich
die AFD wird ihre Haltung zur
Einwanderungspolitik die im
Parteiprogramm nachzulesen ist und die
vollständig im Einklang mit dem
Grundgesetz steht nicht abändern doch im
Netz greift die AFD genau diese Rhetorik
auf so könnte das heimliche Treffen
brisant werden für ein mögliches Verbot
der
AFD und mir zugeschaltet ist Natascha
Strobel sie ist Politikwissenschaftlerin
und Autorin mit den Schwerpunkt
Rechtsextremismus und Faschismus guten
Abend guten Abend wie überraschend sind
für Sie diese Verbindung ist diese
Verbindung zwischen der neuen Rechten
und der AFD die wir da
sehen die Verbindung ist nicht
überraschend die Qualität dieses
Treffens und wie offen hier Pläne zuur
Abschiebung zur auuser landesbringung
zur Vertreibung von verschiedenen
Menschengruppen diskutiert worden ist
also die Qualität darf man mindestens
erstaunt
sein haben Sie diese die Teilnehmer die
wir da jetzt gerade in dem Beitrag auch
gesehen haben und dieses Format
überrascht oder anders gefragt was sagt
das darüber aus dass ich dieses Netzwerk
im geheimen Treffen will um einen
solchen Plan
auszuarbeiten das zeigt für mich vor
allem dass es eine Sammlungsbewegung
innerhalb der neuen Rechten innerhalb
des Rechtsextremismus gibt man muss sich
das sofort vorstellen es gibt
unterschiedliche Gruppen parlamentarisch
publizistisch aktivistisch m Finanziers
und so weiter die sehr lange nach dem
Prinzip gearbeitet haben also wir kommen
uns nicht in die Quere und wir treten
öffentlich nicht voneinander auf
strategisch distanziert man sich aber
alle Arbeiten ungefähr an demselben und
jetzt sehen wir eine neue Phase wo man
doch recht offen miteinander kooperiert
äh wo Unternehmer mit einer Figur wie
Martin selner zusammenarbeiten das ist
ja nicht irgendwer sondern das ist
ein qu die Person die frontperson der
militanten aktivistischen rechtsextremen
bis neofaschistischen Szene im
deutschsprachigen Raum genau das wäre
meine Frage bzw meine Bitte also
redelsführer Martin selner 34 aus
Österreich
holen Sie uns einmal bitte ab also wofür
steht er und ja wer ist Martin selner
Martin selner ist groß geworden im
neonarzissmus in Österreich im Umfeld
von Gottfried Küssel Gottfried Küssel
ist die wichtigste Figur des
neonarzissmus in der Zweiten Republik
Küssel musste dann ins Gefängnis und ab
da hat selner begonnen sich
selbstständig zu machen quasi war an
verschiedenen Projekten vor den
identitären schon beteiligt und wurde
dann zum Gesicht und zum Chefideologen
der identitären Bewegung hat aus
Österreich sehr enge Kontakte nach
Frankreich V allem unterhalten und auch
die identitäre Bewegung in Deutschland
geholfen wieder mit aufzubauen ist
sehr klar im Umfeld von eigentlich im
engsten Kreis von Kubicek
und schnell Roder zu verorten was sowas
wie die Zentrale der neuen Rechten im
deutschsprachigen Raum ist und hat sich
in den letzten Jahren nachdem es in
Österreich eng geworden ist für die
identitäre Bewegung aus verschiedensten
Gründen
m sehr so begonnen quasi zum zum
rechtsextremen Ideologen das seene zu
werden mit verschiedenen Büchern und
publizistischen Beiträgen und in dieser
Funktion reist er gerne durch die Welt
und hält verschiedene Vorträge das
Konzept der Migration aber auch der
große Austausch das sind natürlich alles
Euphemismen
ähm sind da sind Beispiele quasi die er
da jetzt propagiert und die er in die
Szene bringen will mhm jetzt ging es bei
dem Treffen ja auch um diesen
sogenannten Masterplan Remigration das
ist ja eine Art von ja Kampfbegriff aus
der rechtsextremen Szene was ist damit
konkret
gemeint
Remigration also das ist ein ein Muster
ähm dem die neue Rechte vololk das
klingt wissenschaftlich das klingt
unverbraucht das klingt nicht so als
würde der etwas jetzt böses dahinter
stehen aber damit sind eben nicht nur
das wissen wir jetzt auch aus der
Korrektiv Recherche nicht nur der
brüszeichen Abschiebungen gemeint von
Leuten ohne Aufenthaltstitel oder mit
negativem
Aufenthaltstitel sondern verschiedene
Gruppen ja einerseits die die keinen
Aufenthaltsstatus haben die auch jetzt
schon muss man sagen in der
Asylgesetzgebung ähm aus der Landes
gebracht werden können und dann aber
auch Menschen die einen Pass haben
aber aus verschiedenen Gründen ein
Aufenthaltsrecht verwirken und dieses
verwirken da steckt natürlich die kcks
dahinter denn wie verwirkt man ein
Aufenthaltsrecht und wer verwirkt ein
Aufenthaltsrecht und es gibt auch
Beispiele äh also nicht nur das
aufendhalsrecht sondern auch den Pass äh
es gibt auch Beispiele äh von diesem
Treffen wo dann über flüchtlingshelfer
z.B geredet wird dass die ja auch nach
Afrika gehen können das heißt es geht um
Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte bis zum wie vielen
Grad bleibt natürlich offen aber es geht
auch um politisch missliebige Menschen
die sich engagieren wie es eben der
extremen Rechten nicht
passt lassen Sie uns noch einmal bitte
auf die AFD schauen und zwar unter
anderem von der AFD bzw nicht mehr ähm
sozusagen in im Bundestag vertreten aber
4er Jahre in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode im Bundestag vertreten
Ronald Hartwig eben 2017 bis 2021 für
die AFD ist jetzt persönlicher Referent
von Alis Weidel also der Parteichefin
zeigt seine Teilnahme an dem Treffen
dass rechtsextremistisches Gedankengut
eben ja bis weit in die Spitze der
Bundespartei hineinragt
ja
m wenn man es vorsichtig formuliert muss
man sagen dass es mindestens kein
Problem
gibt also es sind natürlich die üblichen
Ausflüchte man wusste nicht dass Herr
selner daran teilnimmt und so weiter
obwohl es in der Einladung
offensichtlich stand aber spätestens
wenn ich dorthinkomme und mit meiner
Position bewusst bin müsste ich
eigentlich aufstehen und
gehen das wä so ein politischer Haus
Verstand wenn man nicht wollen würde
dass man in Verbindung gebracht wird ähm
ich glaube nicht dass ich hochrangigen
PolitikerInnen politische PR oder
Politik erklären muss ä dass das nicht
geschehen ist zeigt doch ganz eindeutig
dass man mindestens interessiert war an
dem was Martin Sellner gesagt hat
mindestens einverstanden war mit dem
was da passiert ist es ist jetzt auch
nicht überliefert dass es als groben
Widerspruch gab dass eine Parteichefin
ihr engstes Umfeld seit unter Kontrolle
haben sollte dass man sich nicht mit
militanten
Faschisten in einen Raum setzt erklärt
sich auch von selbst also entweder hat
sie ihr engstes Umwelt nicht unter
Kontrolle oder es geschah unter
Wohlwollen genau die Reaktion von Alice
Weidel haben wir schon gehört die eben
gesagt hat man werde ähm man werde
sozusagen die Haltung äh zur
Einwanderungspolitik so wie sie nach
Ansicht der AFD Vorsitzenden eben im
Grundgesetz steht und im nicht im
Grundgesetz steht sondern in Einklang
mit dem Grundgesetz ist nicht abändern
es gibt dazu aber auch eine andere
Reaktion von einem AFD
Bundestagsabgeordneten und zwar von Rene
Springer bei Ex ehemals Twitter da
können wir vielleicht einmal zusammen
draufschauen und zwar sagte er wir
werden Ausländer in ihre Heimat
zurückführen millionenfach das ist kein
Geheimplan das ist ein Versprechen für
mehr Sicherheit für mehr Gerechtigkeit
für den Erhalt unserer Identität für
Deutschland so geht es dann in diesem
Tweet weiter dazu passt eine Frage die
wir bei Youtube bekommen haben von Gary
steht das nicht sogar in deren
Parteiprogramm und ist das seit Jahren
bekannt also woher jetzt diese große
Empörung ja ich glaube die Empörung ist
einerseits über die Zusammensetzung
dieses Treffens
ähm über den Charakter das äh was
offensichtlich hier viele hochrangige
Leute wert befunden haben
ähm
sich zusammenzutun und dieses Thema
konkret zu besprechen
das du dezidiert auch über Leute
gesprochen wird die einen deutschen Pass
haben und man denen nach Gesichtspunkten
von Ehrenamt politische Aktivität und so
weiter denenentziehen will oder diese
Leute ausweisen will anhand der
Gesichtspunkte wurde so offen natürlich
nicht kommuniziert bis jetzt auch wenn
es in diesem Konzept der Remigration
immer enthalten war und man muss sich ja
vorstellen was hier so kühl verhandelt
wird oder was jetzt so abgewiegelt wird
was bedeutet es denn wenn ich Menschen
unabhängig ihres
aufenthaltsstatuses aus der Landes
bringen will gegen deren Willen gegen
deren
Verwurzelung aufgrund
von
Migrationsgeschichte nicht
angepasst keine Liebe für deuts das sind
all diese Dinge die man heute gelesen
hat
in in diesen Kreisen
oder von politischer Aktivität oder von
Ehrenamt dann reden wir hier von
Säuberungen dann reden wir hier auch von
ethnischen Säuberungen wenn es eine
Rolle spielt bis in wie vielten Grad
ich Deutsche bin oder ich Österreicherin
bin oder vielleicht Europäerin bin
und das ist den nicht mehr
eine semantische Auslegung von was man
hier spricht sondern das ist ein
Unterschied ob das im Einklang mit der
Menschenrechtskonvention ist oder nicht
ich kann nicht also der Pass ist ja
nicht wir dir nicht nach gut dünken
vergeben sondern das ist ja ein ein
recht ich habe ja Rechte als
Staatsbürgerin und ein Recht ist dass
ich nicht willkürlich behandelt werde
und das ist aber genau das was hier
gefordert wird wenn wir davon sprechen
ähm dass quasi der Lebenswandel dazu
beiträgt ob ich weiter meinen Pass
behalten darf oder
nicht die Pläne die wir jetzt gehört
haben die bei diesem Treffen offenbar
oder dieser Plan der da verhandelt wurde
der scheint ja sehr weit fortgeschritten
und sehr konkret zu sein bisher ist es
den etablierten Parteien hier in
Deutschland aber nicht gelungen da ja
überzeugende Konzepte vorzulegen um eben
gegen diese Entwicklung ja vorzugehen
welche möglichen Strategien sehen sie da
aktuell also wenn wir von den anderen
Parteien sprechen dann müssen sich diese
bewusst werden was hier gespielt wird
die AFD ist Teil der extremen Rechten
die AFD ist eine extrem rechte Partei so
wie der resement National oder die
fratellity die Italier äh die
Schwedendemokraten die FPÖ die SVB die
vi wer auch immer das sind nicht
rechtspopulistische Parteien oder so
kipparteien diese Parteien sind Teil des
Spektrums der extremen Rechten und damit
sind sie nicht normale Parteien wie alle
anderen sie sind nicht Teil des
demokratischen
Spektrums und desen muss man sich
bewusst werden und dementsprechend kan
man sie auch nicht so behandeln mm aber
was mus wenn ich da einmal re also was
muss konkret
passieren man muss sie
einerseits Fernhalten von all Funktionen
wo sie über Menschen bestimmen können
und andererseits muss man natürlich auch
verstehen warum in einer Zeit wie jetzt
in der
multiplen in Zeiten von multiplen Krisen
die extreme Rechte
aufsteigt weil es weil sich als
Alternative präsentieren K die hat auch
im
Namen und wenn die demokratischen
Parteien es nicht schaffen eine
lebenswerte Zukunft zu zeichnen
vorstellbar zu machen den wird immer ein
Teil bei der extremen Rechten bleiben
weil hier die negativen Emotionen
gefangen werden die werden auch befeuert
aber dem kann man auch mit einem
positiven Zukunftsbild Kontern nur
bürokratisches verwalten und zu sagen es
wird so ein bisschen schlechter werden
[Musik]
ist nicht besonders anziehend es fehlt
dringend eine positive Zukunft mhm Frau
Schubel was ja jetzt auch nach der
Veröffentlichung dieser Recherche noch
mal verstärkt diskutiert wird ist eben
ein Parteiverbotsverfahren für die AFD
vielleicht abschließend kurz inwiefern
kann ein mögliches Verbotsverfahren eine
Radikalisierung auch beschleunigen und
wie stehen Sie
dazu ich war hier lange sehr skeptisch
ich bin nach wie vor skeptisch was so
ein Verbotsverfahren angeht einerseits
kann es Radikalisierung befeuern also so
wir haben sie euch immer schon gesagt
die sind gegen uns und so weiter
andererseits sind die gesellschaftlichen
Verwerfungen schwer zu kalkulieren also
bis hin zu Aufständen Mobs und so
weiter
andererseits neige ich dazu zu sagen man
sollte es zumindest sehr genau prüfen
die juristische Prüfung das können
andere Leute machen aber die Geschichte
hat uns doch gelehrt egal wie elegant
oder unelegant es ist zögern ist immer
der falsche Weg wenn es um sie extreme
Rechte bis zu faschistischen recht
rechten geht s man muss do schon sehr
schnell sehr entschlossen handeln den
Demokratie und
Faschismus passen nicht zusammen und
können auch nicht lange nebeneinander
existieren sagt die
Politikwissenschaftlerin Natascha
Strobel vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
für die Einschätzung heute abend DANKE
DANKE SCHÖN ja es gibt natürlich seit
dem bekannt werden dieser Recherche oder
seit dem bekanntwererden dieses Treffens
auch viele Reaktionen auf dieses
Extremisten treffen auch aus der
Bundespolitik und zwar hat Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz dazu bei Ex und auch bei
Instagram heute folgendes Statement
gepostet da können wir einmal gemeinsam
reinschauen wir lassen nicht zu dass
jemand dass wir in unserem Land danach
unterscheidet ob jemand eine
anwanderungsgeschich
Einwanderungsgeschichte hat oder nicht
wir schützen alle unabhängig von
Herkunft Hautfarbe oder wie unbequem
jemand für Fanatiker mit
assimilationsfantasien ist wer sich
gegen unsere freiheitlich demokratische
Grundordnung richtet ist ein Fall für
unseren Verfassungsschutz und die Justiz
dass wir aus der Geschichte lernen ist
kein bloßes Lippenbekenntnis Demokratin
und Demokraten müssen zusammenstehen
soweit der Bundeskanzler ihr habt das
Statement hier auch noch mal gesehen
auch ruderich Kiesewetter von der CDU
hat sich dazu geäußert er ist
stellvertretender vorsitzend des
Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums im
Bundestag das klingt ein bisschen
sperrisch sperrig die sind aber unter
anderem zuständig für die Kontrolle der
Geheimdienste und auch
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann hat
sich dazu geäußert wir hören mal rein
was die beiden gesagt haben das zeigt
eindeutig dass die AFD entgegen aller
Beteuerungen sich viel weiter im
Rechtsextremismus radikalisiert und wir
dürfen auch nichts ausschließen bisin zu
einem möglichen Verbotsverfahren wenn
man einen solchen Antrag stellen wollen
würde muss man bei einer Sache sich
sicher sein dass man dann nach
menschlichem Ermessen sicher sein muss
dass er auch erfolgreich sein wird denn
würde man ich sag mal hier ein Gamble
eingehen also mit dem Risiko spielen mit
einem relevanten Risiko spielen dass man
selber gar nicht fest davon überzeugt
ist dass es äh zum Erfolg führt dann
droht hier natürlich ein prsieg für die
AFD also der Bundesjustizminister Marco
Buschmann ist da noch vorsichtig die
Diskussion über ein
Parteiverbotsverfahren nimmt aber wieder
Fahrt auf und wir wollen deswegen jetzt
einmal die Frage stellen ob die AFD denn
wirklich verboten werden könnte und
darüber er ist mir jetzt schon
zugeschaltet kann ich jetzt sprechen mit
dem Rechtswissenschaftler Professor
Christian walthoff von der humbal
Universität Berlin der das möchte ich
gerne noch ergänzend ergänzen vorstellen
2013 im Auftrag des Bundesrates für ein
NPD Verbotsverfahren vor das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen ist
guten Abend nach Berlin guten Abend Herr
waltorf ihre Antragsschrift damals 2013
die sie zusammen mit Professor Christoph
Möller verfasst haben war rund 250
Seiten stark das geht also um es mal
salop zu sagen nicht einfach so so ein
Parteiverbotsverfahren was braucht es
damit ein solches Verfahren eröffnet
werden kann das imppd Verbotsverfahren
war damals sehr gut vorbereitet durch
die Nachrichtendienste des Bundesamt und
die Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz
und die hatten uns über 3000
Belegstellen 3000 Beweisstücke zur
Verfügung gestellt als Tatsachenbasis
für ein solches Verfahren das heißt wenn
man über ein AFD Verfahren jetzt
nachdenkt und die Chancen ob das Erfolg
haben könnte bräuchte man erstmal eine
Materialsammlung der Verfassungsschützer
mhm bevor wir gleich auf dieses mögliche
Verfahren schauen vielleicht noch einmal
auf das NPD Verbotsverfahren warum hatte
das keinen
Erfolg in einer potierten
Kurzzusammenfassung des Urteils von 2017
würde ich sagen das
bundesverfassungsgricht hat klar gesagt
das ist eine Nazipartei die echt
verfassungsfeindlich die
rechtsextremistisch ist und unsere
Ordnung beseitigen will sie ist aber so
unbedeutend dass wir sie nicht verbieten
möchten also inhaltlich gab es gar kein
Problem bei der PD äh aber es ist halt
eine sehr kleine Partei die auch immer
schwächer geworden ist und das Gericht
hat dann ein neues Kriterium die
Potenzialität eingeführt die so im
Grundgesetz gar nicht drin steht und
gesagt die Partei ist so unbedeutend
dass wir sie nicht verbieten
wollen welche Unterschiede sehen Sie
denn zwischen dem Verfahren damals und
einem möglichen AFD
Parteiverbotsverfahren ein ganz
centraler Unterschied ist dass das
Parteiprogramm der NPD das ist auch
heute noch dasjenige von 2012
ähm eindeutig diese völkische Grundlinie
in allen politischen Aussagen zum
Ausdruck bringt also viele Passagen des
NPD Parteiprogramms lesen sich wie das
NSDAP Parteiprogramm von 1920 ich habe
mir heute Nachmittag noch mal das
Parteiprogramm der AFD angeschaut das
ist nicht
rechtsextremistisch das enthält auch
nicht die Aussagen die jetzt vom
Korrektiv aufgedeckt wurden das enthält
sogar in Passagen Bekenntnisse zum
Grundgesetz man kann jetzt sagen dass
ist nur vorgetäuscht oder so etwas aber
das Parteiprogramm das im NPD Verfahren
ganz wichtig war für die Zurechnung
dessen was die Partei macht ähm das
hätte man bei der AFD nicht mhm wir
bekommen dazu die ganze Zeit auch Fragen
bei Youtube und eine Frage die natürlich
viele interessiert ist Bruno schneeh hat
sie uns gestellt wie wahrscheinlich wäre
denn so ein Verbotsverfahren hätte
dieses Erfolg und was wäre wenn es
scheitern würde wie gesagt eine seriöse
Abschätzung über die Erfolgschancen
könnte man nur machen wenn man Material
hätte allein das was jetzt dieses
recherchenetzwerk Korrektiv aufgedeckt
hat das würde nicht reichen das muss ja
auch der Partei erstmal zugerechnet
werden das war ja keine
Parteiveranstaltung dass da jetzt
hochrangige parteifunktionäere waren
geht schon mal in die Richtung einer
möglichen Zurechnung aber alleine würde
das nicht reichen das heißt man bräuchte
eine ähnlich umfangreiche
Materialsammlung von den
Nachrichtendiensten von den
inlandsgeheimdiensten die flächendeckend
recherchieren
äh wie ist das Potenzial ist das der
normale Zustand der AFD oder ist das ein
ausreier dann könnte man eine seriöse
Abschätzung machen ob ein Verfahren
vielleicht Erfolg haben würde und ich
würde auch noch darauf hinweisen wollen
dass das Verbotsverfahren 4er Jahre
gedauert hat ab Antragstellung ab
politischen Beschluss ist durchzuführen
sogar 5 Jahre das heißt ein
Schnellschuss mit dem man jetzt
irgendwie politische Konkurrenten
vielleicht aus den landtagsfahlen im
Herbst heraushalten könn
wäre das ganz sicher nicht damit haben
Sie schon eine Frage beantwortet die wir
gerade bekommen haben die nämlich auch
in die Richtung gen wie lange würde das
dauern bis zur nächsten Bundestagswahl
wäre das sie haben die Landtagswahl
angesprochen aber bis zur nächsten
Bundestagswahl wäre das ja wenn wir ihn
jetzt richtig zuhören auch niemals durch
uns fragt noch jemand und zwar iüber
Youtube wäre ein AFD Verbotsverfahren
nicht trotz geringer
Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit moralisch
richtig wie würden sie das Bewerten das
ist natürlich ein legitimer Einwand aber
wenn es bei der NPD war es nicht so
schlimm dass sie nicht verboten wurde
weil ja gesagt wurde die Programmatik
und die Aktivitäten der Partei sind klar
verfassungsfeindlich das heißt es gab
kein Gütesiegel in Anführungszeichen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts dass diese
Partei für unbedenklich erklärt hat sie
war halt nur zu unbedeutend man wollte
sie nicht verbieten wenn aber bei einem
AFD Verbotsverfahren rauskommen würde
das reicht nicht für die
Verfassungswidrigkeit auf die
Gesamtpartei bezogen dann wäre das ja
eine Art Gütesiegel aus Karlsruhe dass
diese Partei doch nicht so schlimm ist
und das wäre natürlich fatal das einzige
was bei der AFD sicher ist dass sie
nicht zu unbedeutend ist um
gegebenenfalls verboten werden zu können
denn Potenzialität besitzt sie ja
leider sie haben den Verfassungsschutz
auch schon angesprochen den
Inlandsgeheimdienst der beobachtet die
AFD schon seit einiger Zeit wir haben da
einmal eine Übersicht vorbereitet in die
wir einmal gemeinsam reinschauen können
im März 2022 hat das Bundesamt für für
Verfassungsschutz die bundesafd als
rechtsextremistischen Verdachtsfall
eingestuft schon ein Jahr zuvor im März
2021 wurde der AFD Landesverband in
Thüringen vom dortigen
landesverfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft der
landesverfassungsschutz in Sachsen
Anhalt bewertet den dortigen AFD
Landesverband seit November 2023
ebenfalls als gesichert rechtsextrem und
seit dezember
2023 gilt das gleiche auch für die AFD
in
Sachsen welche Rolle spielen diese
Einstufung denn überhaupt diese
Einstufungen haben zur Folge dass der
Verfassungsschutz überhaupt aktiv werden
kann und beobachten darf und das ist ja
erstmal die erste Grundvoraussetzung für
ein mögliches für ein potenzielles
Verbotsverfahren aber man muss bedenken
dass das gesichert rechtsextrem oder
rechtsextremistischer Verdachtsfall das
sind die juristischen Kriterien damit
der Verfassungsschutz aktiv werden kann
damit vpersonen eing chlust werden
können oder solche Sachen damit die
Material sammeln können die beobachten
können das ist aber nicht der Maßstab
für ein Parteiverbot für ein
Parteiverbot müsste sehr viel mehr
hinzukommen wie würde sie wir haben es
jetzt in diesem Stream schon immer
wieder ein bisschen besprochen aber
vielleicht können Sie uns die einzelnen
Schritte noch mal darlegen also wie
würde ein solches
Parteiverbotsverfahren ablaufen mit
welchen Konsequenzen sie haben jetzt
gerade die V Leute z.B auch angesprochen
die können ihre Arbeit ja nicht einfach
so weitermachen genau also erstmal
müsste man Antragsteller finden das kann
die Bundesregierung der Bundestag oder
der Bundesrat sein also man bräuchte
eine Mehrheit jeweils die den Antrag in
Karlsruhe stellt und sobald der
politische Beschluss gefasst ist also
auch noch vor Einreichung einer
antragschrift müssen alle
geheimdienstlichen alle
nachrichtendienstlichen Tätigkeiten
abgestellt werden also wenn man etwa
vpersen in den Vorständen etwa in
Thüringen oder in Sachsen haben sollte
was wir ja natürlich nicht wissen dann
müssten Sie von diesem Tag an wie man so
schön sagt abgeschaltet werden also
jeder Kontakt müsste unterbunden werden
und das hätte zur Folge dass während des
Verbotsverfahrens keine validen
nachrichtendienstlichen Informationen
aus dem Inneren der Partei mehr bekannt
werden
würden welche sie haben es gerade auch
schon angesprochen für dieses konkrete
mögliche Verbotsverfahren sehen sie
jetzt erstmal ja keine keine Auswirkung
durch dieses Treffen in Potzdam trotzdem
das so würde ich es nicht sagen also
wenn das ein ein Modell flächendeckend
wäre wenn man nachweisen könnte dass die
Partei so denkt und dass das die echten
politischen Ziele wären dann wäre das
schon relevant aber dass eben zwei
hochrangige funktionieren noch einige
andere Leute
als nicht Parteiveranstaltung da
teilgenommen ist ist natürlich
bedrückend und schlimm und überhaupt
nicht in keiner Weise zu rechtfertigen
aber es müsste noch mehr kommen man
müsste viel mehr flächendecken
Informationen haben um das Risiko
abschätzen zu können okay eine Frage die
ich doch gerne an Sie weitergeben würde
wäre es denn denkbar die Frage an den an
den Rechtswissenschaftler dass man
einzelne Personen wie z.B Björn höcke
mit rechtlichen Mitteln eben
ausschließt also grundsätzlich gibt es
ein sogenanntes Parteienprivileg das
heißt eine Partei die eine politische
Partei die nicht verboten ist darf auch
gar nicht benachteiligt werden nur das
Bundesverfassungsgericht kann das
feststellen aber es gibt im Grundgesetz
eine bisher auch noch gar nicht genutzte
Möglichkeit in diesem Konzept whrhafter
Demokratie dass nämlich auch einzelne
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
an ihrer grundrechtsausübung gehindert
werden können das nennt man Verwirkung
der Grundrechte Artikel 18 unseres
Grundgesetzes und da wir jetzt das
Problem dass man damit das Parteiverbot
dass man nicht erreicht oder nicht
erzielen will jetzt nicht umgehen darf
so als Parteiverbot des kleinen Mannes
aber theoretisch können extremistische
Bürger die ihre Meinungsfreiheit und
ihre politischen Grundrechte gegen im
Kampf gegen das Grundgesetz ein setzen
denen kann dieser Grundrechtsschutz
entzogen werden davon wurde noch nie in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Gebrauch gemacht Herr Professor waltoff
dann gerne abschließend noch einmal wir
haben jetzt viel darüber gesprochen es
wird in diesen Tagen wie gesagt jetzt
auch wieder verstärkt diskutiert ein
mögliches Parteiverbotsverfahren für die
fd sollte man sollte weiter darüber
nachgedacht werden oder würden Sie auf
Grundlage ihrer Erfahrung davon abraten
das ja in Gang zu bringen nein ich würde
auf jeden Fall drüber nachdenken und die
entsprechenden politischen Instanzen die
das gegebenenfalls ja in Gang setzen
könnten müssen sich rückversichern bei
ihren Sicherheitsbehörden wie die Lage
ist und wie gesagt ohne dass man diese
gesicherten Informationen hat kann man
auch nicht abschätzen ob der das
erfolgversprechend und damit sinnvoll
ist sagt Professor Christian waltorf
Rechtswissenschaftler an der humbal
Universität Berlin vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit und für das Gespräch sehr gerne das
war unser ZDF heute live zu dem Treffen
von Rechtsextremen in pozdam im
vergangenen November und den möglichen
Konsequenzen für die AFD wenn ihr dazu
die aktuellen Entwicklung weiter
verfolgen wollt oder Hintergründe lesen
wollt dann schaut gerne vorbei in
unserer ZDF heute App danke fürs
zuschauen für eure Fragen und bis zum
nächsten Mal